[La musique]
quant à Charlemagne il est le plus souverain
puissant de l'Europe médiévale mais son
immense empire brisé en un seul
multitude de principautés des douanes et
trois langues différentes
et difficile à unifier avec le traité
de verdun l'empire de boue se partage entre les
trois neveux de charlemagne charles le chauve
reçoit l'ouest de la france qui
deviendra l'actuel france lothario
reçoit d'abord le titre impérial et le
le centre de la france appelé lotharingie qui
ses trois fils se partagent alors en Lorraine
Bourgogne et Italie et Louis le Germanique
reçoit l'est de la france c'est à dire
Allemagne antique
mais un nouveau danger vient de
scandinavie les vikings du danemark
et de Norvège appelés les Normands
après avoir envahi les îles britanniques
ils traversent la Seine dévastant leurs visages
le roi de france charles le simple pense
les réjouir en leur donnant le ducat de
normandie et les baptisant chrétiens mais
tandis que les Normands lui jurent obéissance
les pillages continuent et ils dévastent aussi
Ligurie
des vents de guerre secouent aussi l'Europe
l'est envahi par un peuple errant
venant de l'oural les magyars et
bungas blancs pillage je
royaumes slaves naissants de bologne et
La Tchéquie menace aussi l'Allemagne mais
le puissant roi d'allemagne en laiton
premier bat la hongrie et fonde le
marquisat d'Autriche pour bloquer le
leurs raids envahissent alors la Bourgogne et
Italie
Le pape entre triomphalement à Rome
Jean XII à la recherche de protecteurs
chrétiens depuis que les musulmans ont
envahit l'Espagne, couronne-le alors
empereur du Saint Empire romain germanique
Le germanique et le premier rais
[La musique]
L'Italie vit une phase avec Otto Primo
de renaissance apparaissent les premiers documents
officiers remplaçant le latin
avec des phrases écrites dans la langue vernaculaire de l'Italie ed
certaines appelées villes portuaires
Les républiques maritimes jouissent de l'autonomie
prospérité politique et économique
[La musique]
la plus ancienne république maritime et pour
deux siècles le plus puissant et amalfi
suivi au fil du temps par gaeta venezia
Gênes Pise
ancona noli et ragusa dans le courant
croatie les républiques maritimes oui
les rendre indépendants de l'empire
byzantins de l'empire germanique et de
Les États pontificaux se disputent le contrôle
des routes méditerranéennes aux Byzantins e
en allemagne et importer des biens de valeur
d'Afrique et d'Asie dans leurs villes
les pièces d'or sont des tartinades frappées
l'utilisation de la boussole est encouragée
technologie de navigation dans sont nés
nouvelles cartes marines avec les pratiques de
échange et comptabilité
les républiques maritimes naissent le
capitalisme finance internationale
droit commercial
[La musique]
quant à l'état pontifical et dans son intégralité
la décadence la corruption règne je
protestation des mouvements religieux
proposer des hommes de grande valeur
moral et valide
administrations et familles romaines oui
lutter farouchement pour le trône papal
[La musique]
aussi la ville sacrée du christianisme
Jérusalem est menacée par les musulmans
Turcs qui se sont propagés en conquérant
l'anatolie byzantine empêchant également la
commerce à l'est
[La musique]
alors au cri de Dieu le pape le veut
Urbain II proclame la première croisade
[La musique]
une armée dirigée par neuf Italiens ed
Européens
il part alors pour la terre sainte et libre
jérusalem livre la syrie et
Palestine à l'Empire byzantin
à cette époque aussi l'empire germanique est
en crise
divisé en deux factions le bien-être dicte
Les Guelfes en italien sont favorables à
pouvoir impérial tandis que les hohenstaufen
dit Gibelins sont partisans
de l'indépendance les conflits entre eux
deux dynasties rendent difficile la
contrôle territorial de l'empire
cela permet à plus de familles
puissant de l'Italie distro mettre les nobles
les évêques fidèles à l'empire germanique
création de municipalités
[La musique]
le nouvel empereur allemand Frederick
barbarossa essaie de restaurer le
propre autorité
attaquer les biens communs et détruire
milan mais les communes forment la ligue
Lombard et le battre dans le bois
dans l'hymne national italien legnano est
la seule ville autre que Rome à être
cité pour cette importante victoire
contre les dirigeants étrangers
[La musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant ce temps les Normands de Roger II
d'altavilla ont enlevé la Sicile aux
Arabes et tricheurs et toast aux Byzantins et
fusionnant leurs conquêtes de l'Italie
au sud ils ont trouvé le royaume de Sicile
un État centralisé et efficace
avec capitale et palerme
le parlement de palerme est l'un des plus
monde antique quand l'empereur
germanique henri sixième se marie
Costanza d'Altavilla leur fils
Frédéric II rejoint la couronne impériale
au royaume de Sicile pour centraliser ses
retour de puissance
[La musique]
connue sous le nom de stupor mundi pour ses
personnalité aux multiples facettes frederick ii
subit le charme de la culture arabe
et entre en conflit avec les papes qui
ils ont excommunié trois fois le pape innocent
iv même le dépose du trône
l'accusant à tort de vouloir
détruire le christianisme en une période
délicate car l'Europe d'aujourd'hui est
envahi par les Tar Mongols menés par les
petit-fils de Gengis Khan qui pille
tout sur leur passage
frederick ii travaille pour s'assurer que je
Les dirigeants européens unissent leurs forces
lutter contre le danger commun
danger qui disparaît soudainement
quand les tartares reviennent en mongolie
tenir une insurrection après la mort
de leur grand khan
[La musique]
les conflits entre la papauté et l'empire
Germaniques ils reprennent avec manfredi le
fils de Frédéric II et cela pousse le
pape français urbain iv demander de l'aide
au frère du roi de France Charles
d'Anjou qui couronne comme roi de Naples et
de Sicile
mais la cruauté de Charles d'Anjou provoque
à la révolte des vêpres siciliennes
massacre de ses hommes parce que je
Les Siciliens appellent les Espagnols à l'aide
de Pierre III d'Aragon, gendre de
manfredi occupant l'île avec le
l'aragon la sicile devient un royaume
indépendant et avec le soutien du duché
de Milan passa sous l'hégémonie
l'espagnol peter iii enlève du français
le royaume de naples qui vient alors
uni au royaume de Sicile sous la
Couronne aragonaise
[La musique]
la papauté
bien qu'entouré de puissances étrangères, il est
déterminé à garder le sien
influence sur les dirigeants chrétiens mais le roi
Philippe le beau n'est pas de France
d'accord
[La musique]
innovateur roi philippe le beau
moderniser la politique avec l'institution
des états généraux en consultant le
noblesse le clergé et la bourgeoisie
en plus d'exiger des impôts également de la
le clergé
cela provoque la colère du pape Boniface
viii et le niveau filippo répond par un
Un geste impensable emprisonne bonifacio
viii et établit une papauté à Avignon
donnant naissance à un grand schisme entre les
papauté de rome et celle d'avignon lo
le schisme provoque 70 ans de guerre entre les deux
papa te faisant profiter du ducat de
urbino qui obtient l'indépendance et la
ville de rome où cola di rienzo
proclame la république romaine en proposant
unification de l'Italie sans papes mais meurt
assassiné aussi florence profitta lo
schisme en étendant sa domination sur
toute la Toscane mais pas dans la république
de lucca qui reste indépendant
en attendant
le roi d'angleterre revendique la couronne
puis la guerre de la guerre a éclaté en france
cent ans la france deviendrait
anglais si jeanne d'arc n'avait pas
persuadé l'héritier du trône charles vii a
reconquérir le pays
en italie les conflits entre empire et
la papauté sont atténuées et cela permet ai
Les municipalités italiennes refleurissent
politiquement et culturellement tous
humanisme jacopone da todi francesco
Pétrarque, Giovanni Boccace et autres
de grands auteurs remplacent
latin millénaire et la langue vernaculaire italienne
avec le dialecte florentin faisant nella
base de la langue italienne
[La musique]
toujours à Florence avec le nouveau courant
culture de dolce stil novo dante
Alighieri révolutionne la littérature
Italien avec l'opéra comédie divine
universellement reconnu comme l'un des
les plus grands chefs d'oeuvre de tous les temps
dans le nord de l'Italie
les municipalités évoluent en devenant des seigneurs e
ce ne sont pas des institutions fortes
reconnu par l'empire et sous le
guide des familles de l'ancienne noblesse
féodal comme moi de la tour je souche je
gonzaga l'estensi et de l'escalier i
Malatesta et Montefeltro
les docteurs les vicomtes et les savoyards
légitiment peu à peu leur pouvoir
jusqu'à ce qu'il devienne comte duchés et
principautés héréditaires et indépendantes
[La musique]
en Italie parmi les républiques maritimes
se battre pour la domination des mers le premier
perdre le pouvoir et amalfi suivi de pise
conquis à Florence puis aussi à Gênes
il s'affaiblit et avec la chute
de l'empire byzantin le seul pouvoir
maritime est resté en Italie et à Venise le
serenissima qui s'étend également sur la
atterrir
cela inquiète le duché de Milan qui
Venise fait la guerre
puis la figure charismatique intervient
par lorenzo le magnifique qui avec son
politique de garantie crée une alliance entre
florence milan et venise formant le
Ligue italienne
[La musique]
le nouvel équilibre territorial
favorise la Renaissance italienne qui
il se développe chez les dames et plus
aussi important que turin milan venise
mantoue ferrara modène florence urbino e
reggio emilia ainsi que dans l'état
papal
[La musique]
la renaissance vient aussi au royaume
de Naples où les Aragonais espagnols
admettre la sardaigne en plus de chasser je
Musulmans des Pouilles
[La musique]
la république de gênes a perdu
puissance militaire mais reste très riche
à tel point que ses banquiers me financent
Les rois catholiques espagnols et portugais du
leur reconquête de la péninsule ibérique
expulser définitivement les musulmans
espagne portugal
alors les grandes navigations commencent
le génois christophe colomb découvre
L'Amérique et l'Amerigo florentin
vespucci départ et retour par mer
du portugal prouve que la terre est
autour de l'influence italienne en Amérique
latina est considérable le venezuela veut
dire la petite venise la colombie prend
du nom de christophe colomb
l'amérique porte le nom d'amerigo
vespucci et de nombreux conquistadors tels que
francisco pizarro sont d'origine
italienne
en 1500 les petits états italiens sont
si riche et plein de biens
artistes que les souverains européens
ne résistez pas à la tentation de
pillez-les en premier pour bouger est roi
de France Charles VIII descendant en
l'italie avec une armée puissante pour
récupérer le royaume de Naples sur lequel
revendique les droits héréditaires de Charles
d'anjou l'arrivée de charles viii choque
l'équilibre politique des États
Italiens dont certains voient en lui
un moyen de faciliter ses projets
avec l'aide française le duc de Milan
Ludovico il Moro expulse son neveu
Galeazzo Sforza qui sape les siens
pouvoir à florence savonarola et son
les opposants aux médecins rétablissent alla
république
à rome les cardinaux hostiles au pape
espagnol alessandro borgia essayer
en vain est sa déposition à Naples i
barons hostiles à ferdinand ii d'aragon
ils espèrent que les Français le renverseront
tout se termine lorsque les États italiens
d'abord favorable à l'invasion
Les français prennent conscience du danger
qui dirige leur liberté milan venise
états pontificaux empire et royaume germaniques
de Naples forment alors une anti-ligue
Français et battre Carlo plus tard
le chasser d'Italie
son successeur louis xii tente à nouveau
envahit l'Italie et conquiert le duché de
milan mais est battu au sud par
Espagnols du royaume de Naples
le défi de barletta remporté par
Chevaliers italiens contre chevaliers
Le français fait partie de ce conflit depuis
sa partie la république de venise oui
s'agrandit en supprimant une partie de Venise
Giulia à l'Empire germanique et au sien
États d'alarmes de la force militaire
le pape papal jules ii se forme alors
à la ligue de cambrai avec la france
espagne empire allemand duché d'
ferrare duché de savoie et marquisat de
mantoue tous unis pour attaquer
Venise et découper ses territoires
mais quand les français battent les troupes
Le pape vénitien Jules II reconsidère
juger la france plus dangereuse que
venise quitte la ligue de cambrai
et avec l'angleterre et la suisse au-delà
à l'empire germanique et à l'espagne que
ils changent de côté de la ligue
saint contre la france
les Suisses ont battu les Français et les
Les Espagnols ont battu les Vénitiens mais quand
le pape jules ii meurt le nouveau roi de
francesco primo bat la ligue
couturière ils tous à Venise avec qui
le nord de l'Italie est divisé
[La musique]
entre-temps l'archiduc d'Autriche Charles
le cinquième des Habsbourg hérite du Saint-Empire
empire germanique
en plus de l'Espagne et du royaume de Naples
[La musique]
François Ier attaque alors le royaume
de Naples lui réclamant des droits
dynastiques jamais battus et menés
prisonnier à madrid par carlo cinquième que
préfère vivre en espagne
plutôt qu'en autriche inquiet
par l'énorme puissance de carlo cinquième le
le nouveau pape clément vii forme le
alliage cognac avec france venise
et Florence
le très catholique charles cinquième pur
l'interdiction du créateur de
protestantisme martin luther qui
défis à la capacité de l'église envoie
en Italie les terribles lansquenets
des soldats protestants allemands qu'il fait
avec les Français emportant leur la
Lombardie et avec le sac de Rome
ils forcent le pape à se réfugier un
Château Saint-Ange
[La musique]
charles cinquième est le souverain dont le règne
le soleil ne se couche jamais mais abdique et le
son immense empire est divisé en deux
son frère ferdinand premier hérite de la
couronne impériale en autriche son fils
Philippe II hérite de l'Espagne et de son
Colonies italo-américaines en plus de
les pays-bas et une région de france
fragilisé par la sévère réforme
protestant par john calvin qui
culmine à paris dans la nuit du st
bartolomeo avec un massacre de
les protestants philippe ii prend possession
aussi du Portugal et de ses colonies
mais quand il envoie le sien en angleterre
armada invincible subit une
désastreuse défaite en France du roi
henry iii désigne comme rouge et un
protestant henri iv et paris pour toujours
Les catholiques ne veulent pas de rois protestants
puis henry iv s'exclame paris c'est bien
une masse
bleu la confession protestante e
donne la liberté de culte à tous
Les citoyens français en Italie je commande
catholiques
le pape combat les protestants avec le
la contre-réforme et la république de venise
affronter les musulmans de choix
Empire turc ottoman mais les tortures
infligés par les Turcs aux prisonniers
Christians donne naissance à une nouvelle ligue
saint formé par la papauté venise et espagne
qui bat lotomatica dans le célèbre
bataille navale de lépante
[La musique]
cependant les nouvelles routes atlantiques
nuire au commerce
Méditerranée de Venise qu'elle conserve
l'indépendance mais perd le pouvoir en
empire allemand de l'hôtel d'autriche
La guerre civile de trente ans fait rage
guerre entre protestants et catholiques qui
étend toutes les puissances européennes
les conflits les dévastaient aussi en Italie
et la robe apportent la pauvreté et la faim mais un
l'art et la musique baroques de rome sont nés
instrumental et en moins dramatique que oui
répandu dans le monde entier
autant que l'opulence de la Renaissance
n'existe plus
Giordano Bruno Galileo Galilei
torricelli caravaggio bernini borromini
corelli monteverdi et autres artistes
continuez le génie italien
[La musique]
de son côté le royaume de Naples est
soumis à la rapacité fiscale
Les Espagnols et les Napolitains surtout je
pauvres rebelles masaniello
la révolte commence soutenue par
la france revendique toujours ses droits
dynastiques sur le trône de Naples
jusqu'à la succession au trône de
espagne de philippe d'anjou neveu du roi
de france espagne et france oui
unir en un seul royaume
cela inquiète les dirigeants européens qui
réclamer des droits à la couronne
Espagnol à cause des nombreux mariages
parmi les familles régnantes
commence alors la guerre de succession
Espagnol qui voit l'empire anglais
germanique la fusion des pays-bas
contre la france et l'espagne france
répond en assiégeant turin mais c'est
défaite grâce au sacrifice de Pierre
micca et à la victoire des armées
impérial dirigé par les ducs de Savoie d
aoste
la guerre se termine avec le traité de
utrecht où passe le royaume de sicile je
ducs d'Aoste qu'ils sont devenus depuis
une maison royale tandis que les Habsbourg
Les Autrichiens remplacent les Habsbourg
Espagnols en possession de la Lombardie
de la Toscane, de la Sardaigne et du royaume
de Naples commençant la domination
austriaca en italie l'espagne s'oppose
occupant la Sardaigne et la Sicile qui
elle considère le sien mais est battue par l'eau
double alliance formée par l'Autriche
la france l'angleterre et les pays bas avec le
traité de la haye les habsbourg riaci
ils prennent la sicile donnant en échange le
sardaigne et savoie que roi de sicile
ils deviennent de petits sardes
[La musique]